why do we like some foods more than
others what is it about burgers and
cakes that we crave
and what is happening in our brains when
we choose what to eat
if you hopped into an mri machine and
were offered a delicious
chocolate milkshake you would see your
brain's reward system
light up like a fun fear right above
your eyes is your orbital frontal cortex
a part of the brain which is especially
developed in humans and primates
here bundles of neurons respond to
different sensations and nutrients
taste smell how smooth and rich the
milkshake feels
and the more your neurons light up the
more delicious the food seems
two things which particularly delight
these reward neurons are
fat and sugar combinations of fat and
sugar
can be even more delightful such as in
that delicious milkshake or
cakes or donuts but your neurons don't
just respond to these sensations
they also activate when you're planning
what to eat in a contest with each other
to get you to choose them
pick me says silky smooth mouthfeel
no me shout sugary sweetness
you never pick me quietly mumbles the
smell of broccoli
and once you have chosen the same
neurons track your progress
and as you eat they get less and less
active as you approach fullness
but we're not entirely at the mercy of
the demands of our orbital frontal
cortex
having information about the food can
make a big difference
hop back into that mri machine and slurp
down some soup
there are two types one is labeled rich
and delicious flavor
and the other is labeled boiled
vegetable water
your neurons light up at the taste of
rich and delicious
and less for boiled vegetable water but
wait a minute
you've been tricked those were both the
same soup
the only difference was the name and
that was enough to completely change
your experience of it
this experiment was also done with wine
telling people that the wine costs more
made their neuron activity increase and
the wine tasted better
another part of the brain involved in
choosing food is the amygdala
the amygdala also has a role to play
when you choose where to go out with
another person
if you've seen what they prefer in the
past your amygdala will have developed
so-called simulation neurons
these predict the choice you think they
will make which you can then
factor into your own suggestions of what
to eat together differences in our genes
are also a factor in how susceptible we
are to the siren call of our reward
neurons
with some people being naturally more
responsive to the reward we feel from
eating sugar and fat than others
scientific experiments give us clues
about how our brains compute our choices
of what to eat but the way we experience
these choices in our lives and in
society
is also complex dr emily countois
assistant professor of media studies
gives her take
so we choose the food we eat for a lot
of different reasons
what's available at the grocery store
what's convenient what's affordable
what do we have good memories about what
tastes good to us
what do we think is healthy what is our
current health status
what defines our ideas about who we are
so when we think about food in the
digital age
one of the biggest things that's changed
the way people eat and the kinds of
foods that they're seeking out
are social media platforms instagram and
the desire for people to be able to take
beautiful food photos
has transformed the idea that you are
what you eat
into you are what you post so we seek a
lot of different things from the food
that we eat
we can seek comfort we can seek a
connection to history to our families to
our heritage
but we can also seek in it a sense of
control when we live in moments
that are full of economic political and
social strife
sometimes we seek in food that sense of
security
and safety so in those moments we
sometimes see people
get really interested in ideas about
naturalness health
and purity as a way to protect ourselves
from contexts
outside of our control so food also
tells stories about who we are
the full complexity of our identity what
we eat to tell stories about our gender
and our sexuality
our race and our ethnicity our social
class or our aspirations about our
social class
the region where we live even whether we
live in an urban or a rural area
what we eat tells these contradictory
complex stories
about who we are in the future we can
use our knowledge of what's happening in
our brains
to design foods that are low in calories
and are still attractive but healthy
and we can help ourselves by
understanding how our reward neurons
plot to get what they want
we can be aware of times that we tend to
make poor choices
like when we choose a food because of
some label which appeals to us rather
than because of its taste
so in the end we are at least not fully
at the mercy of our reward neurons
we can use our understanding to help
design healthy foods
and make healthy choices